[Musik]
mein name ist super herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal
ja das war jetzt unangenehm allerdings
geht es ja bereits im titel eingeblendet
meine lieben freunde geschoss heute
gemeinsam die unnötigste websites der
welt an und wir starten direkt mit
dieser website wo man einfach eine
klopapierrolle eingeblendet bekommt
die website zeigt einem allerdings nicht
nur diese wunderschöne klopapierrolle
sondern man kann auch was machen uns war
das klopapier runterziehen
allerdings ist das nicht das einzige was
man machen kann sondern man kann das
papier wieder aufrollen
also hochziehen und ja mach mal weiter
mit der nächsten website das ist nämlich
die website slap dort kommen allgemein
habe ich euch alle web setzt sich heute
zeigen nochmal unten in der beschreibung
verlinkt also schaut euch gern mal unten
rein was man hier machen kann ist dass
hier
man hat einen aal und kann in einer
person ins gesicht schleudern
bestimmt unangenehm für die person auf
dieser website namens kotzen das einhorn
kann man einfach seinen vor und
nachnamen eingeben und dann sagt die
website einem wie der einnahme von einem
aussieht und zwar wäre ich dunkel kurs
hat sich ein bisschen an die dinkelbrot
aber wir machen weiter mit der nächsten
websites und zwar ist die website you're
getting old da muss man seinen
geburtsdatum eingeben bei mir
beispielsweise 21 zweiter 1996 dann
klickt man einfach auf grund die website
zeigt einem verschiedene fakten über
einen selbst an wie beispielsweise wie
viele tage man schon alt ist was der
geburt steine ist wie oft das herz schon
geschlagen hat mainz beispielsweise 870
millionen mal
mein herz schlägt bisschen schneller als
es da angezeigt wird und dass hier sind
halt noch nicht alle informationen die
man angezeigt bekommen sondern wenn man
weiter runter scrolls sieht man auch
noch ganz ganz viele weitere sachen über
den eigenen geburtstag als er dort auch
gern mal vorbei link dazu in der
beschreibung
die website heißt endless horse und es
ist ein endloses fährt man kann hier
runter scrollen
ob man tatsächlich nie die diese
websites cat bounce und der name ist
programm freunde hier sind einfach
katzen die auf den boden fallen und dann
dort liegen bleiben wir sind also
teilweise auch wieder hoch hüpfen und
das aber schon die ganze website das
hier ist ein spiel und zwar heißt es
scheint wie invisible wir können einfach
mal auf start game klicken und da gehört
schon hier sind das relativ leise
[Musik]
wir haben die kaum gefunden ja diese
website hier heißt hey punkt com und ihr
seht schon was die webseiten macht sie
zeigt einfach hey hey das war es auch an
der stelle von der website dann wieder
das ist ja heute das circa dümmste video
das ich je hochgeladen habe auf meinem
kanal aber wir sind niemals bei der
hälfte angekommen freude das ist die
nächste webseite wenn man hier nach oben
geht kommt der mittelfinger wenn man
nach unten geht kommt der zeigefinger
und leute die schon länger auf meinem
kanal zu sehen sind
ja ich war natürlich leute unter euch
die schon länger abonnent sind von
meinem kanal und sich schon länger meine
videos anschauen wissen dass nicht
einige websites sehe ich bisher hier
schon vorgestellt habe schon mal gezeigt
habe allerdings sind eine menge neue
zuschauer dazu gekommen sind jetzt vier
millionen leute der lupo also er
verdanke thomas zum newcomer im
endeffekt niemand das ist auf jeden fall
die nächste website uns was ist der mail
die visualizer man kann auch switch to
female hier drücken dann ist es der
female body visualizer und dann kann man
hier beispielsweise eingeben wie
großmann ist ich bin zum beispiel 194
ich liege tatsächlich drei und vier und
18 83 33 333 angeben und kann sich dann
hier anschauen wie der eigene körper
wäre ich gehe zum beispiel 19 mal die
woche zum sport
ich bin so so so so so und so
ja das bin genau ich
ja das ist die nächste website da spielt
einfach eine fahrstuhlmusik und die
website zeigte einem in sekunden wie
viele sekunden des eigenen lebens man
auf so was passiert schon aus dem
fenster geschmissen hat also danke
wirklich auf dieser website geht es
darum dass verschieden farbige wände
einfach von einem wegfallen und ich weiß
nicht wie es euch gerade geht aber mir
wird gerade ein bisschen schwindelig
ja
er schwamm recht grad wir machen weiter
mit der nächsten website
ja das ist die website fleischfreien und
das ist ein fliegendes spiegelei dieser
website hier ist eigentlich sogar ganz
cool und zweitens die scale of the
universe 2 website
man kann sich einfach hier das universum
anschauen indem man hier nach ganz
rechts beispielsweise geht dann ist man
ganz ganz ganz ganz groß und das
universum und dann kann man
beispielsweise auch wieder reingehen und
die summe immer weiter rein ins
universum meine lieben freunde bisher
bei den kleinsten teilchen angekommen
sind und zwar lang länger
oder quanten schaum
oder string ok haben wir gehen jetzt auf
jeden fall noch mal einfach so quasi
ihnen die mitte beziehungsweise ein
bisschen vor die mitte und zwar bleiben
wir hier stehen
da sehen wir auch wir müssen noch ein
bisschen weiter wenn meine glasmurmeln
wir haben quadrat sollen us- penny wenn
wir weiter hoch gehen den wir schon okay
haben wir dinosaurier reichen hier haben
wir burj khalifa wenn wir weiter auch
genommener planeten also ist eigentlich
ziemlich cool und lehrreich für ein paar
minuten website nummer 4000 die ich euch
zeigen möchte ist das hier und zwar kann
man einfach draufklicken und dann wird
dort geteilt
jetzt denke ich hier drauf damit dass
geteilt wenn ich hier wieder der
aufstieg wird das geteilt damit dass
geteilt jetzt kann ich die ganze zeit
hier rum klickten auch verschiedene
dinge drauf klicken und das was wir
schlussendlich dadurch machen das
einfach die teile zu teilen
hallo
für leute die absolut gar nichts zu tun
haben mit ihrer zeit und in dem leben
viel spaß damit dass jetzt die nächste
website und zwar steuert man die rechte
hand und auf die linke hand muss man
drauf malen mit einem kugelschreiber
wahrscheinlich man genau man muss sich
selbst auf jeden fall die fingernägel
lackieren dafür hat man in der rechten
hand irgendwie so ein stift und und
nagellack dingsbums und dann muss man
halt hier alles mögliche anmalen und ihr
seht schon jetzt bin ich beispielsweise
fertig
und ja das war es dann auch schon diese
website hier ist auch mega cool und zwar
geht es darum dass man hier einen rat
hat und man kann das rad halt andrehen
und dann dreht sich das rad ja keine ins
fahrradgeschäft geben diese websites
mister nice hens und wir können hier
ja
[Musik]
wir können die website kurz und angenehm
dass jetzt die nächste zeit die ich euch
stolz präsentieren möchte und zwar es
ist einfach ein computer der gegen einen
anderen computer dame spielt ich sage
weiß gewinnt dieses spiel meine lieben
freunde sollten nicht gewinnen weil ich
selbstverständlich meinen youtube-kanal
schließen ein paar sekunden später
das hier jetzt meine lieben freunde so
ca die unnötigste webseite sehen werden
und zwar muss man einfach seinem aus
irgendwohin packen da lassen und dann
eine person
[Musik]
ich bewege meinem aus als beispielsweise
mal hier hin und zeigt diese person
darauf jetzt bewege ich meine maus
wieder ein taxi hier ganz rechts am rand
und wir sehen schon das zeigt auch eine
person darauf jetzt gehe ich mal hier
ganz in die mitte beispielsweise wo das
lade symbol ist und da haben wir dass
dort auch eine ja ich habe keine hobbys
und will kommen wir zu den letzten
beiden webseiten nicht vorbereitet habe
ja
das ist die komplette
hat die high straight im keller und wenn
ich die seite aktualisiert
jetzt die lila
oder grün
pink oder gelb
und das ist auch schon die letzte
unnötige website die ich euch im
heutigen video vorstellen möchte und
zwar heißt spend bill gates money da
kann man jetzt einfach irgendwas kaufen
beispielsweise acht big macs und dann
seht ihr habe ich noch dass sie übrig
ich kaufe jetzt beispielsweise mal
800.000 big macs und ich habe immer noch
das hier an geld übrig wir können dann
mal weiter runter scrollen sehen halt
immer teurere sachen wie beispielsweise
lamborghinis verkaufen als mal acht von
dann kaufen wir noch einen neuen ferrari
sam 20 helikopter weil die braucht man
natürlich auch dann würde ich mir
definitiv noch 70.000 hauses kaufen da
noch sechs feier trucks falls meine
häuser brennen sollten
dann kaufe ich mir noch zehn jachten
dann kaufe ich mir noch mit acht raketen
für 60 millionen dollar pro rakete man
mit seinen sieben freunden mal zum mond
fliegen will für ein wochenende und wenn
wir ganz unten angekommen sind sehen wir
noch mona lisa einen cruise ship 1 ndm 1
mlb team und eine fällt ihm also ich
würd sagen wir kaufen uns auch noch 20
nfl teams und wir sind immer noch bei 43
milliarden dollar
wenn ich so reich wär
überlegen weil ich es recht sein
[Musik]